carol peltier's journey is one of the
most
wide-ranging in the walking dead she
begins as a battered wife but ends up a
queen
a warrior and above all a survivor with
a spin-off focused on her and daryl
dixon on the horizon
there's never been a better time to
explore her entire story
carol had been a survivor for many years
prior to the story's
start she meets and marries ed peltier
who quickly becomes abusive toward both
carol and their daughter sophia
when the apocalypse hit the family tries
to go to atlanta
only to realize that the government is
in more of a napalming mood than a
helping one
while stuck in traffic the peltiers
befriend lori
shane and carl who managed to get them
and a handful of other survivors to a
campsite
just outside the city while they figure
out their next move
there ed's abusive behavior continues
but now it's happening under the
watchful eye of a former police officer
and a group of like-minded women
shane eventually beats an appropriate
amount of snot out of ed for slapping
carol in front of everyone
as a result of his injuries ed isn't
exactly in fighting shape when walkers
descend
on the camp he's killed and eventually
put down before becoming a walker by
none other than carol herself
marking her first step towards
independence i'll do it
it's my husband after the survivors go
to the cdc and discover how dire their
situation truly
is they set out on the road once again
unfortunately
they are waylaid when their rv gives up
the ghosts
when a herd of walkers approaches carol
is separated from sofia
rick tries his best to save her but he
too is separated from the child in the
thick georgia woods
it isn't long before the group discovers
sophia is a walker
locked up with her undead brethren in a
barn and rick is forced to put her down
when the farm they've taken refuge at is
overrun by
walkers carol isn't much help in the
ensuing battle
with no one to guide her and no real
fighting skills to speak of
she must rely on others to stay alive
after a brief
failed attempt to replace her former
husband with daryl
carol begins to understand that her
survival is in her hands
and no one else's season three begins
with a minor time jump that reveals a
very new carol
she's gained a lot more confidence in
the intervening months and a whole lot
of new skills
ranging from combat to medicine the loss
of her family has hardened her in a
unique way
she's no longer afraid of ed's wrath nor
of losing sophia
when the survivors hole up in a prison
she busies herself with first aid and
preparations to deliver lori's baby
unfortunately a walker attack sets those
plans aside
and carol is trapped alone in an overrun
part of the prison for several days
fortunately daryl finds her and nurses
her back to help
as she once did for him when he was
injured looking for sophia
their relationship is stronger than it's
ever been when daryl's older brother
merle returns to the picture carol sees
a lot of ed and merle
and tries to encourage daryl not to lose
the man he's become
in favor of reverting back to who he was
around his older brother
in their final interaction together
before he dies merle comments on how
different
carol has become since the last time he
saw her at the camp outside georgia
well you don't seem scared or nothing
anymore
i'm not when the war with the governor
and woodbury begins
carol proves just how right he is by
encouraging
andrea to assassinate the governor after
the citizens of woodbury are welcomed
into the prison
carol begins teaching the children how
to kill walkers
soon a flu starts spreading throughout
the prison and carol takes it upon
herself to execute two carriers
in an effort to stop the spread when
rick figures out what she's done
he banishes her from the group as a
result she's away when the governor
returns to destroy the prison
in the aftermath of the attack carol
finds tyrese
who has rescued young sisters lizzie and
mika
as well as lori's baby judah together
they find their way to a small cottage
where they decide to figure out their
next move while there
lizzy starts to develop a soft spot for
walkers
carol and tyrese try to get her to
change her mind after a few encounters
with dangerous walkers
but it's all for naught lizzie
eventually kills mika
convinced that she'll be back as a
walker and that everything will be fine
what's more lizzie confesses that she's
planning to do the same to the baby
realizing how far gone she is and how
much of a threat she poses to the rest
of them
carol and tyrese silently agreed to
execute her
which carol now a grizzled survivor is
willing to do
they agree to never speak of it again
just
look at the flowers eventually the group
arrives at terminus and carol and tyrese
realize that it's crawling with
cannibals
who have taken their friends hostage
carol launches a one-woman
full frontal assault on the compound
almost single-handedly taking it down
with some clever explosions and a herd
of walkers thanks to her bravery
she's welcomed back into the group but
it isn't exactly the boon to survival it
once was
with the prison gone and terminus a
proven sham
the remaining survivors wander the woods
aimlessly
after beth is kidnapped by a group of
vicious survivors living at a hospital
carol ends up getting hit by a car and
taken into the belly of the beast
where she spends a good deal of time
unconscious before
daryl and company rescue her their fates
change when aaron arrives and invites
them to be a part of the alexandria safe
haven
but carol is skeptical of this
apparently apocalypse-proof community
she reverts back to her cheery old
housewife persona
lying and wait for the moment her true
new nature will be needed
it doesn't take long before she and rick
discover a man in the community
pete is abusing his wife and kid carol
stops baking cookies for a moment to
threaten pete's life
ultimately turning that particular
conflict over to rick
who executes him with rick pretty much
in charge of alexandria
carol is forced to abandon her housewife
act
when a group of nomadic survivors known
as the wolves
infiltrate the camp and start killing
its citizens she dons a disguise
and manages to almost single-handedly
stop the invasion
blowing her cover within the community
forever fortunately
her blood-thirsty nature is curtailed a
bit by the arrival of morgan
who's on a warrior monk kick and doesn't
want to kill living people
that attitude coupled with a new love
interest by the name of tobin
helps carol pull back from the abyss of
violence
unfortunately this comes just as the
group fires their first shots in what
becomes an
all-out war with their toughest enemy
yet the saviors
when rick agrees to take on an outpost
held by their new enemy
carol finds herself kidnapped alongside
a pregnant maggie
and she's forced to use every bit of her
cleverness to escape
however the experience sours her to
warfare
prompting her to leave alexandria and
tobin
unfortunately she's too late as the
saviors are already monitoring who goes
in and out of the colony she's gravely
wounded in a one versus five skirmish
just when it looks like she's about to
be executed morgan
arrives to save her please
just let me go
it's not your turn carol wakes up in the
kingdom
an enigmatic colony where everyone
defers to the judgment
of king ezekiel after some light-hearted
bonding with ezekiel
she decides she still wants to be alone
but settles on an abandoned cottage
that's not too far from the kingdom
she crosses paths with the alexandrians
again when rick and the gang seek the
kingdom's help in overthrowing the
saviors
carol has an emotional reunion with
daryl during which he lies
and tells her that the saviors haven't
hurt any of their people
morgan reveals this to be a lie however
and carol opts to get
back to what she does best protect the
people she cares about
we have to get ready we have to fight
[Music]
by the time she convinces ezekiel to
bring the kingdom's forces to
alexandria's aid
negan has managed to breach the walls of
the safe haven and subdue rick and his
fighters
the brash villain is about to execute
carl as punishment for what he sees as
rick's rebellion
when he's stopped by the united forces
of the kingdom and the hilltop
and just like that carol finds herself
as a general in the kingdom's army
against the saviors
it doesn't take long for carol to become
one of the most important fighters in
the rebel army
she leads right beside king ezekiel as
members of his faction ambush a savior
outpost
in the hope of obtaining heavy weapons
just when the mission seems to have
succeeded however
the group is cut down by a hail of
gunfire only
ezekiel carol and jerry are left
standing
heroically carol makes one more bid to
obtain the weapons
but ultimately decides to save her
allies instead these events leave
ezekiel in a spiral of self-pity carol
employs tough love to help him out of it
and the two eventually become makeshift
parents to a youngster named henry
when negan launches a counter-attack on
the kingdom carol
is able to get everyone out in time they
retreat to the hilltop where they
quickly learned that negan has also
taken out
alexandria with just one safe haven left
the entire army prepares for a last
stand a battle ensues
in which carroll is forced to put tobin
down in the fray
henry runs off forcing carol and morgan
to go looking for it
killing walkers and saviors along the
way they rejoined rick's army just in
time to witness
all of the savior's guns backfire
allowing them to finally
defeat negan a year and a half later
carol reigns
as queen of the kingdom having started a
romantic relationship with ezekiel
meanwhile their colony the hilltop and
alexandria are doing their best to
rebuild and assimilate the saviors
and their sanctuary into their ranks
unfortunately things aren't going well
as constant infighting and small acts of
defiance threaten the very
terse alliance carol personally takes
over control of the sanctuary briefly
but it doesn't last as several of the
more defiant members leave just before
rick sacrifices himself to unite the
groups
six years go by and she and ezekiel
continue to keep the kingdom running
while raising young henry in an effort
to make him more useful
she escorts him on a trip to the hilltop
so he can learn
blacksmithing and finishes off a group
of former saviors along the way
i swear you'll never see us again
[Music]
i know
back at the kingdom ezekiel is busying
himself with a fair that he hopes will
convince the three
allied colonies to sign a charter that
will bind them to each other for life
this finally comes to fruition when the
alexandrians asked the kingdom to harbor
lydia
the daughter of the whisperer's leader
alpha furious at the kidnapping
alpha built a border that she makes
clear the group is never to cross
marking the border is a line of heads on
spikes
including henry's carol is devastated by
henry's death
she leaves ezekiel shortly after getting
the remaining survivors to the hilltop
after the kingdom succumbs to
deterioration she sets off to live
life by herself as a fisherwoman but
eventually returns
still holding a grudge against alpha
when a satellite crash lands near the
oceanside colony
they all have to cross the border to put
out the fire this causes alpha to
unleash
a relentless herd upon them when they
meet for peace talks
carol pulls a gun on alpha fortunately
alpha is in a forgiving mood
it is then revealed that carol has been
taking pills to keep awake
both as a survival strategy and to avoid
dreams of what her life could have been
after the group discovers this she's
taken back to alexandria for treatment
she promptly leaves to take revenge on
alpha's herd
however in a shocking twist it's
revealed that killing the herd is just
one part
of carol's revenge plan she also frees
negan from captivity in alexandria
with the sole purpose of having him
assassinate alpha
so you bring me off his head
[Music]
and that's what the people will remember
you for
he succeeds but carol isn't able to
finish off the hurt
she returns to the survivors and
attempts to sacrifice herself
in order to walk the zombies off a cliff
but she's saved by lydia at the last
moment
effectively ending the whisperer's reign
of terror
carol returns to the camp where she has
an important conversation
to fully reconcile with daryl who she
spent the better part of a year
at odds with despite otherwise being
each other's greatest ally
daryl asks if she got what she wanted
during the battle
she admits without actually saying it
that she now realizes
she never actually wanted to die even in
a heroic sacrifice
with the whisperers a thing of the past
carol is ready to take on all comers
with her best friend at her side and a
new zest for life
daryl then asks if she may want to hit
the road for new mexico
to which she notes that there are still
things they need to do at home first
this is the clearest setup for her
spin-off in the walking dead franchise
beyond the flagship series ending after
season 11.
norman reedus told entertainment weekly
that he and melissa mcbride's series
will be more of a road show than
anything else
meaning the duo will fight one more
battle before going off into the sunset
together
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]